-Lili, I wanted
to ask you about a tweet
that you tweeted out
that made me laugh.
Because you were at Coachella
and you tweeted out,
"Where can I get a Mountain Dew
at Coachella?"
[ Laughter ]
Was it hard to get a --
-Couldn't find one.
Never found one.
And that was at 10:20 p.m.
So you know I wasn't entirely...
[ Laughter ]
-Dehydrated. Okay. That's it.
Sorry, sorry.
I hate to put words
in your mouth. Yeah.
But you do the Dew.
You're a Mountain Dew --
-I do the Dew. My mom drank it
when I was in the womb.
It's her fault.
[ Laughter ]
-No way. Come on.
-Yes. Yes.
-I thought it would be kind of
fun if you and I maybe --
There's a few different
Mountain Dew-inspired products.
These are real.
-Mm-hmm. Right, right.
-Not paid for by Mountain Dew,
but I thought we could give it
a try and see what you think.
-Yeah, let's try
some Mountain Dew products.
-This is for you.
This is a lip balm.
-Ooh!
-This is a Mountain Dew
lip balm.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, it's darker
than you would expect.
-It is. Mountain Dew
is not this dark a green.
-A little bit of a scent.
Like a lime.
-Yeah. A little bit of a lime.
Okay.
-I don't want to mess up my --
-Oh, yeah. Your lipstick.
Yeah, me neither.
[ Laughter ]
Let me see. Hey.
-Moisturizing.
-Not bad.
-Yeah, that was okay.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. I like this. Not bad.
I give this a --
-It's like a six out of ten.
-Six out of ten. Sure.
I'll give it a seven.
-Okay.
-Alright. That's good.
Oh. Ready for this one?
-Yeah. Yeah. Ooh.
This is scary.
-This one's very interesting.
It's Mountain Dew-inspired
ice cream called Mountain Moo.
It's made by Moo-Ville Creamery
in Michigan.
We got it sent to us
just for you.
Mountain Moo.
-Aww. How kind.
-Here we go.
Oh, you need a spoon. Sorry.
You're like, "How do I eat it?"
Yeah. Okay. Here we go.
Alright. It's the right color.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I would not go out of my way
to eat this.
-It's kind of interesting.
I don't know wh--
It doesn't quite make
the right turn, does it?
-It tastes like the flavor of
milk after you have Froot Loops.
Like, the milk afterwards.
-Now I'm jumping back in.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] Take another.
Don't you kind of think?
-I kind of like that.
Now I like it more.
-If you think of it going in --
-Tastes like Froot Loops milk.
-Yeah.
I would not eat that again, no.
-I would. I would totally do it.
You totally sold me on it now
and changed it.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
This next one is
an alcohol-related product.
-Okay. I'm old enough.
-Here we go. Let's pretend
we're at Coachella.
-Oh!
-Here you go.
-This would be a dream
at Coachella.
-This is a distillery. It's
a Mountain Dew-inspired vodka
called --
by Three Olives in Jersey City.
-Okay.
-This flavor is called --
ready for this -- Dude.
-Dude.
-Yeah. Cheers.
-Cheers.
-Cheers, dude.
♪♪
[ Mouths word ]
-It is actually not as bad
as I thought it was going to be.
-That's not bad. But this one --
I would do Dude.
[ Laughter ]
-Mmm.
But this one -- The next one,
this last one here,
this is a real --
I have not tried this.
I thought maybe we could
try this together. This is real.
This is Mountain Dew
Flamin' Hot.
[ Woman in audience cheers ]
Have you ever tried this?
-I'm such an original Dew girl
that I don't...
-The orange?
-...partake in Code Red
or anything like that.
So this is scary.
-Smells good.
♪♪
Ooh. It's g-- No.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh. It is spicy!
-It's got a burn after-taste
to it.
-Yeah, it's a little bit
of burn in me.
-Sorry. You want more Dude?
-No, I'm okay. Well, maybe.
Let's take a little bit more.
-Take a Dude.
-Wash it down?
-Wash it down. There you go.
Thank you for trying
that stuff with me, pal.
-Ooh. That's not good.
-Now, look. Here we go.
-It's worse the second time.
-I want to talk
about your movie.
-Okay.
-"Look Both Ways."
-Yes. "Look Both Ways."
-Congratulations.
You produced this, as well.
-Thank you. I did. Yeah.
-Do you like producing?
-I do.
I love to be
in control of things.
-You do?
-I really do.
-You get a little --
You get some voice.
You get to go...
-Well, yeah, because, you know,
it's better to have
the "executive producer" title,
otherwise you're just,
like, a bossy actor.
-Yeah.
-Rather than I'm like,
"No, no, I have this title.
I'm allowed
to make these decisions."
-Yeah, you are. Yeah.
-So it makes me feel good, yes.
-How do we describe
"Look Both Ways"?
I like the idea of this.
-"Look Both Ways."
It follows Natalie
on the eve of her graduation --
college graduation.
She takes a pregnancy test,
and her life severs off into
two different parallel lives,
one where she is pregnant
and one where she's not.
And I think what I loved most
about the movie
and when I read the script
was that there is no wrong path.
There isn't one that you're like
"Oh, that was the bad one."
So I think both --
There's silver linings in both.
And it's comforting to know
that there isn't one decision
that you can make
that will just completely derail
everything in your world.
-Well said.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lili Reinhart
in "Look Both Ways."
Take a look.
-They're probably
just not expecting it
to play out that way.
-They weren't ex--
I wasn't expecting this.
I did not see
"single unemployed
22-year-old mom"
on my tarot card reading
that Kara gave me last month.
-What about our plans?
What about naked Sundays
and furniture with sharp edges?
We were supposed to go
to Barcelona next year!
-I've been thinking
about that quite a bit.
It would make sense if...
-What?
-If you and I just --
[ Indistinct arguing outside ]
If, um...
-It's not gonna be --
Oh, no. Unh-unh!
-Let's get married.
-No! Nuh-unh! No! Get up!
That's not happening!
-Hey! Hey!
-Get up!
-Yeah! Lili Reinhart, everybody!
"Look Both Ways"
begins streaming
August 17th on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody.